Before we get started, we wanna remind you
that we have the Bleak Creek
conversations coming up
at the end of October,
the beginning of November.
It's a live show, it's very special.
We're gonna be there for it.
And then a very special special
Bleak Creek conversation
on Sunday, November third in Los Angeles
where you can meet and greet some
of the Mythical crew members
including Cotton Candy Randy
and more and then of course
we've got some more tour stops.
The regular live in concert
tour at the end of November.
All the details for that
are at RhettAndLinkLive.com.
Visit, you know what.
It doesn't take a commitment
to go to RhettAndLinkLive.com.
Just check it out, see
where we're gon' be.
Tell people who you know
in the area or show up.
We'll make it special, we promise.
We will.
Now on with the biscuit.
Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link, survivor
of a pyramid scheme.
Whenever I introduce myself
now, that's what I'm gonna add.
'Cause that's what I wanna be known as.
Okay.
The guy who escaped
a pyramid scheme.
Are you gonna skip over
the thing that we say
at the beginning of every podcast?
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're gonna answer the
question, how did I, Link,
the guy who escaped a pyramid scheme,
escape a pyramid scheme?
Okay, you've got me.
I've clicked.
You wouldn't be able to hear anything
unless you would have somehow--
Right.
Clicked play
in some place.
So we're gonna explore
that question and these are,
we're gonna explore that via
a question that we received
from a Mythical Beast
and some other questions
that we received.
We're gonna give our best, we're
putting our advice hats on.
We're gonna be talking
about multi-level marketing,
our personal experiences with that.
We might work up some ire.
We might get angry, or we might get happy.
We might laugh, we might cry.
I think--
Might offend somebody.
I think you might get angry.
I don't think it's about us getting angry,
I think some people will feel attacked.
You know, but that will be
unintentional if that happens.
Before we get into those questions,
I do wanna say we got a lot to
be excited about around here.
Seems like every single year,
at the end of the year,
starting around October--
October's a--
Things get busy
for the Rhettster and the Linkster.
A Mythical month, you know?
We always got things happening
in the month of October.
October 11th, your birthday.
My birthday, but we got
of course our novel,
"The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek"
coming out on October 29th
and the Bleak Creek
conversations and all that
that goes along with that, but
we're doing something very,
very special.
We are celebrating
with a Carolina classic.
We're gonna throw a big
pig pickin' party here
at the Mythical studio.
We're calling it the Bleak
Creek Barbecue Bonanza
and two very special
guests and their guests
will be chosen at random and
here's how we're gonna do that.
And flown to Los Angeles
to have the pig pickin' with us.
Yeah and here's how we're gonna do that,
so if you pre-ordered the
novel at any time in the past
or you pre-order the novel now,
or you got a ticket to
Bleak Creek conversations,
you go over to BleakCreek.com,
you enter that proof of
purchase, you can enter,
each proof of purchase
for a book counts once
but you can buy as many books as you want
and enter for yourself,
you just can't keep
putting the same one back
in over and over again.
And then we're gonna randomly
select two of those people.
And we have to say, for legal purposes,
no purchase necessary to enter.
Void where prohibited and
full details on the website.
But in a not legal sense--
BleakCreek.com.
We are super excited about that
and we're gonna do it as
authentically as we possibly can,
like a whole hog--
If anything is worth doing,
it's worth doing with pig.
I mean the, and there's a very--
Well that's, I don't know.
I can't stand by that statement.
Anything worth doing is worth
doing with a pig picking.
Okay good.
Pig pickin',
which is the scene of the opening chapter
of "Lost Causes of Bleak
Creek" is a pig pickin'.
Yeah and it's also what we have used
to signify big moments in our
lives at least growing up,
so we're like why don't
we bring this to LA?
Can't you do a pig pickin' in LA?
Let's figure out how
and let's bring some Mythical Beasts out.
Pre-order the book,
it's good for everybody.
You wanna go ahead and get into one
of these questions though?
Yeah, after the break we'll get into
the multi-level marketing
but I wanna give,
we have a question about showers
and it's a good occasion
for me to give an update
on your shower advice from
last week 'cause I did take it.
But let's read--
Okay.
The question.
This question comes from @fallingstargirl.
My boyfriend leaves
the shower curtain open
after he takes a shower,
it drives me nuts.
I don't like the inside of
my shower being exposed.
Plus, I spent good money on the curtain
to complete my bathroom decor.
What you guys think of this?
So he leaves the shower
open but the curtain,
I would call that meaning
the curtain is scrunched.
It's closed up on itself but
which leaves the shower open.
We all know what's happening here.
I don't think anyone
needed that clarification.
Well, you know.
But I know your brain
works in a strange way so--
I needed it.
It's fine that you said it out loud.
I mean I'm feeling your
pain 'cause if you leave
a shower curtain scrunched up,
it starts to get that pink stuff on it.
How on earth, of all the
things that could grow,
even in a damp, shower-like environment,
how could it turn a shower curtain pink?
Do you know what I'm talking about?
I think that might be
from you and your family.
My family doesn't generate pink mold.
You've never seen a pink
residue on a shower curtain?
I've seen--
Growing up--
I've seen like a--
I remember seeing it a lot.
A gray, maybe like a
brown mildew of some kind.
But pink?
That might've been something else,
that could have been an alien.
Or I distinctly remember we had like,
you know, you got the
decorative shower curtain,
which might be made of fabric or something
but then you got the plastic
shower curtain on the inside
which you know, keeps all the moisture in.
And that thing became pink at the bottom.
And slimy probably.
And slimy.
Well thankfully, I currently--
It might have been because
of the pyramid scheme.
I currently do not have to
deal with a shower curtain
because our shower has a
door and actually the last,
every house I've ever
lived in in California
has had a shower door
and not a shower curtain.
Must be because of the earthquakes.
You don't want that
curtain wrapping around you
during a big one.
You don't have a bathtub
with a shower in it.
That's really when you know
you gotta have a shower curtain
when you're taking a shower in a bathtub.
But I know growing up--
Which is how I grew up.
My brother and I had
the traditional bathtub
with a shower in it and I know
that we kept that thing open
all the time 'cause it
was just a boys' bathroom.
And I know my mom would come in there
after she cleaned things
up and like close it again
and then we would just open
it again 'cause like why?
Yeah I feel your pain.
I don't know how you
motivate your boyfriend
because it's one of those things that like
there's so many things that
I care about, you know,
it's like I go in after my
kids and I turn off the lights
and I close their drawers
and I pick up their clothes
and towels off the floor.
I cannot get my sons to pick up the towel.
I'll single out Lincoln, I can't get him
to pick up the towel off the floor
or like the clothes that
he took off before he got
in the shower and I've
tried all types of things
and I have not succeeded.
I don't know how to do it and--
You know how it's gonna stop?
Just don't go in there.
When they move out.
And then they begin managing themselves.
I know but she doesn't
just want her boyfriend
to move out, she wants to
have some sort of hope.
I just wish I had a simple solution.
I mean it's the right thing to do not just
for decorative purposes but
also for sanitary purposes.
Maybe if you take a microscopic image
of that slimy stuff that
he's helping to create,
it's kinda like when you
look under your fingernails,
the stuff under your
fingernails under a microscope,
you won't bite your fingernails anymore.
Well what if, I mean,
when did you recently,
when did you recently show me videos of,
was this a Mythical Society thing?
Where you showed me videos of
you going around your kids--
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
I tried, I got so
frustrated going behind him
and turning off the lights
and picking up all the stuff
that I would video me doing all of it
and then send him the video.
But the key point you're leaving out is
you would make disgruntled sounds
without speaking.
You would just communicate like the way
that humans communicated
before we had words.
I was grunting.
Well the second--
And you were grunting
your disgust and your disappointment.
Well the second video, I kept saying why?
Why?
Why, why are these underwear in the sink?
Why, why?
I think you should stick with the--
Why?
Stick with the grunts, man.
Don't resort to language
because you're trying
to connect with a deeper
part of their brain,
like the impulsive part
of their brain that is,
we're not talking about the neocortex
at this point, right?
You're trying to get down
into the instinctive parts
of the brain to change
deeply rooted behaviors,
so I think that what
@fallingstargirl could do
is she could video herself, first of all,
get a closeup of the
wrinkled up shower curtain
and hopefully some
mold, even if you need--
Oh you like my idea, that's good.
Even if you need to add a little mold
to get some kind of culture started there,
and you get a closeup
of that and you make a ,
whatever your disgruntled sound is,
and then you have yourself
opening the shower curtain.
Again, you're not saying anything,
you're not confronting them in the moment.
You're not confronting them
when he's at the house.
You just send him these videos
and you do it every single day.
Eventually, he's going
to get tired of seeing
these videos and then he'll start,
it'll change his behavior.
I did it two days in a row and then,
my kids just kinda, they laugh at me.
It just wasn't that effective.
It's so much easier, first of all,
she's dealing with an adult man.
And I'm not, what are you saying?
You're dealing with--
Oh.
You're dealing with children.
And also, you're, what
you're doing is intruding
in some respects on their space.
I know you're their dad
but you're going into
their personal, personal
area and doing like
a controlling dad kinda thing.
Yeah.
This is the shower that they share.
So you know, I feel
like this is a slightly
different territory but I
think your technique is sound.
I just think she needs to take,
you need to stop your technique and--
Give it to her.
Transfer it to
@fallingstargirl and she needs
to do it on a regular basis
and I think it will impact
the behavior of the boyfriend.
I think something really
embarrassing needs
to be inside the shower
that he's gonna want
to hide by closing the curtain.
Like--
A picture of him naked.
Yeah.
Even when he's not
in the shower naked, he's
always in the shower naked.
'Cause you know when he's
inside the shower naked,
he closes it 'cause he
doesn't wanna expose himself.
Right.
But if you take a picture
and then go to like, what is
that bighead.com is a place
you can get things blown
up to paste onto the wall?
Not a sponsor.
I don't even know if that's it but--
I think that is it.
Take a picture with a high res camera.
When you blow things
up, you want it to be,
you want the detail to be there
and then you just vinyl paste him
on the inside of the shower.
Now you're gonna have to deal with that
when you take a shower but he will,
I guaran-damn-tee you he will
close that shower curtain
from here on out.
Forget about the videos.
Or you could just use permanent marker
and just write his secrets
inside of the shower.
Eh, not as fun though.
Yeah.
Speaking of get in the shower--
I wanna hear your update, but what is it?
Fathead.
Fathead.com,
again, still not a sponsor.
Not bighead, Fathead.
I wanna hear your update
but this does remind me 'cause I wanna ask
if you remember this
when you were in England.
I noticed it in Scotland
but then when we got
to England, until we
got to the London hotel,
which had a normal walk-in
shower with a door,
every single shower that I used in the UK,
no shower curtain and I'm talking bathtub
with shower built in so traditional.
Mm-hmm.
But there is a
glass door that is on a
swivel that only goes half-way
down the bathtub.
So did you see this?
I saw it in five different places.
So there's a bathtub and then there's like
a plexiglass wall built
above the bathtub that then--
Only goes, it goes from
like, you got the shower head
coming out of the wall--
Oh yeah yeah.
And coming from that wall, you have--
It comes out three quarters.
It comes out half.
50% of the way.
Okay.
Not three quarters.
And so--
So then, yeah,
so when you're standing in
the tub taking a shower,
all the water, and you're
standing in the middle of the tub,
that's where the plexiglass ends
and the water bounces off of you.
It's assuming that no water goes past you.
If the water passes you which--
If it hits the top.
I mean listen,
I'm an American and I guess I shower
in a particular American way
because what I found is that
and my dad and my mom and my
brother and my sister-in-law
and my wife and everybody
that was with me was like
we're getting water--
Water everywhere.
All over the floor.
When we went to London, we
had the same thing, yeah.
What is it?
What are we doing wrong or
what are they doing wrong?
Because this is not a good design.
How is this a good design?
Yeah I mean water's all over the floor.
It did happen to me in the
Airbnb that we were staying in.
What are we missing?
Could you just #EarBiscuits
explain that to us--
Yeah I don't know.
On the internet
because I don't know if you
guys wear like a large sponge
while you shower that
absorbs all the excess water.
I don't know how you overcome this.
They're like constantly
trying to block all
of the water and bounce it back into the--
I don't wanna be thinking
about that when I'm showering.
It's high pressure.
Well low pressure in some places.
Well if it's low pressure that helps.
But it's a high pressure situation.
Yeah right.
Anxiety.
I have a door on my shower.
Not a shower curtain.
That fully seals?
Oh yeah but the thing that
I'll do is when I get out
of the shower, I annoy Christy
because I leave the door open
so that all of the moisture
inside of the shower
can dissipate more
quickly than if you close,
if you seal it back up
and then it just stays wet
and I think that's when
you start to produce,
bacteria starts to grow and--
Mold.
I fear that pink slime.
I've noticed.
But then Christy has
told me a couple of times
that it's a totally clear glass door that
when I leave it open, she's
ran into it a couple of times.
So now I have to just leave
it cracked a little bit.
Just leave a little gap in it.
You think about a lot of other things
than the things that I think about.
I know, I'm gonna die young.
I'm gonna die young, man,
but I've thought so hard.
I've never thought about
this particular thing.
I just get out of the shower.
I don't know, I couldn't
tell you what happens.
Well this morning and yesterday morning,
and for, well, hang on a minute, yeah.
Well I've tried it a few times.
I've tried your advice, okay.
Stare down.
I get in the shower,
I look out the window.
On the previous podcast you told me,
"Don't try to hide from your neighbor
"when he's driving into work, leaving his,
"just give him, assert your dominance."
Right.
I'm lathering up and here
he comes gettin' in his car.
He's facing me, he's sitting
in the driver's seat,
before he puts it in reverse
and looks behind him.
I'm like oh gosh, this is it.
Yep.
And I instinctively started hunching.
I was like come on Link, pull it together.
Yeah, moment of truth.
Be dominant.
And I was actually washing
my face at the time
so I had to stop so I could stare at him
so my forehead was lathered up.
Okay, this is changing everything.
I got a lathered up forehead.
I don't know, I don't know.
I'd already done the shampoo
so it was, I had a low
lather right at the brow.
Okay.
And I'm just looking at the guy,
hoping that he does not look at me.
But he's not close enough
that I could immediately tell,
you know with the
reflection on the windshield
and everything and I'm
like, just hold your ground.
Maybe he'll put it in
reverse and take off.
Right.
I can tell he put it in
reverse and then he's like
gonna look over his
shoulder and apparently,
he wasn't looking at me
until he started to look
over his shoulder--
Uh-huh.
To back up and I notice,
he started to turn,
then boop, he looked back,
he had noticed something.
Right.
Me.
Yeah.
Naked bathing man neighbor
asserting his dominance.
With a light lather.
On his forehead.
He saw me, he definitely saw me.
Uh-huh.
And I just, I--
You held your ground?
I, ooh, I flinched.
Oh gosh.
But I didn't duck, I didn't like--
You flinched?
Buh and like fall down.
I flinched and then I, I
don't even think he picked up
on the flinch and then I just
looked at him and he like,
he looked at me, man and
then he put it in reverse
and he took off.
Can I see what the stare
is that you're making?
It's a long way, it's like
picture suds on my forehead
and I'm--
'Cause I'm realizing
that my advice could
backfire at this point.
I was washing my face.
Because if you're--
I have a special face brush.
Because--
I'm washing my,
I'm doing it!
Okay.
Look at me.
All right.
I'm washing my forehead
with the face brush.
I got a special brush for my face,
it's round, I go in a circular pattern
like my mom taught me back
when I used to use her Noxzema.
She's like "this is how
you don't get zits, son,
"wash your face in a circular pattern."
So I have my own face
brush and I'm doing that
and then all of a sudden I see him,
I see him, oh there he is, and I like,
I lower the face brush and I just,
this, this is what I did.
That's the look?
Yeah, don't blame it on the look.
He couldn't see the details.
Well, I guess.
He knew I was looking
at him, I do know that.
You should've practiced,
because that look can be misinterpreted as
you're interested.
Oh.
What, no it doesn't, I'm
just looking, I'm just.
I mean, you're in your shower though,
think about it for a second.
It's gotta be intimidating,
almost like Children of the Corn.
Like lowering the eyebrows?
It just can't seem--
Here's the thing--
In the least bit seductive.
Nothing that you're
gonna say now is helpful
because it's too freaking late.
The next day after that,
I'm taking a shower
and I'm like oh yeah, the stare down,
and I look out there, the car's gone.
Oh, you won.
He leaves at a different time now.
He leaves at a different time.
Yeah, you did it, man, you did it.
You forced his hand.
Yeah, he goes to work earlier.
Yeah, he's like I'm not
gonna deal with this.
He probably was like,
man, he takes a shower
the same time every day.
And he's finally stared me down.
I think he wants more
from the relationship.
Either way, you've won.
No, he's thinking that about me.
He thinks I want more
from the relationship
than the neighborly banter.
He wants to move beyond it,
so now he's gotta avoid.
All I'm saying is--
When I see him at the mailbox,
I don't know what I'm gonna do.
That's a different,
that's a completely
different MO at that point.
Act like nothing happened.
Yeah, yeah, that's friendly
neighbor situation.
That's like hey man, how
you doing, how you been?
Hey, hey.
I haven't been looking
at you from my shower.
Haven't seen you in a while,
while I'm in my shower
naked, lathering myself up.
That's a different Link.
That's the, again that's the Link
that needs to be brought
out in case of emergencies,
not the everyday friendly Link,
you know, business as usual Link.
So mission accomplished then, huh?
Yeah, that's very awesome.
Okay, cool.
We've got more questions, but first
we're going to promote
something, I don't know,
what is it, are we gonna
promote the website
and the store and the things
that you can buy at the store,
Kiko, or is there something else?
Let's say Mythical.com.
Mythical.com.
There's so much you can browse.
We just keep putting new stuff up there.
It's fun.
It's becoming like a online--
Mall.
Shopping mall.
It's just like--
A mini mall.
Yeah, that's what it's becoming.
I mean, I love it.
I go on there and just scroll through it.
We've got gift certificates over there,
because there's so many
options at this point,
it's almost like Amazon.
What am I gonna get you from Amazon?
I'm gonna get you the ability to get
whatever you want from
Amazon in a gift card.
Well, if you have an Amazon gift card,
you can go to our Amazon
store, Amazon.com/Mythical.
That's true, I mean, we've
got all the bases covered.
That's what we specialize in.
We put, listen, you need
to keep wearing stuff,
you need to keep it fresh,
so we're gonna keep designing stuff
and it's gonna be fresh.
Yeah, and we're gonna make sure--
We've got a great team designing crap.
We're gonna make sure
that you don't look like
you shop at one place,
that's why it's always
a little bit different.
Everything's a little bit different.
Where'd you get that?
Oh, I got it at the same place,
I got it at Mythical.com.
Exclusively.
But it's different, isn't it?
And you're different.
There's something different about you.
You're cool,
and that's why you shop at Mythical.com.
I'm different, yeah I'm different.
All right.
How about another question?
You want ask it?
Um, sure, sure, this gets
into the pyramid scheme stuff.
Oh gosh, go on.
@Sneakynin asks, a friend, put that down.
A friend has been
brainwashed by an MLM scheme.
Well tell us how you really feel about it.
She's been roped into all the
feel-good seminars and is losing money.
She's become a bad
friend because, all caps,
everything comes back to the MLM message.
You joked about it in your
song "Friends 'Til the End,"
but how would you handle this situation?
We talked about our
opinions on MLMs before.
But we about to go back to the whale.
And, can I, I mean I
know you have a story.
I just have a life experience.
You have an anecdote.
I want to say a couple of things.
First of all, I know some of you listening
are involved in MLMs.
And let's be specific,
it could be Amway, it could be Herbalife,
it could be Herbal Life,
it could be Mary Kay,
it could be, what's the one,
what's the one we make fun of in the song?
Uh, LuLaRoe.
LuLaRoe.
LuLaRoe?
That's it, with the leggings, is that it?
Leggings.
But she had to go when
she joined LuLaRoe, yeah.
Pampered Chef I think does this.
Still around, huh?
So let me say--
Tupperware parties from back in the day.
I'll say a couple of things.
We use the term pyramid
scheme in the question
at the top and possibly in
the title of this video,
I don't know, um.
Let me just say first of all,
pyramid schemes and MLMs
are not the same thing,
and people who are in
MLMs are very offended
by being called a pyramid scheme,
and so I want to recognize
that right off the bat,
that pyramid schemes are illegal, right?
It's a scam.
They might be better
described as a pyramid scam,
and usually in a pyramid scheme,
there's actually no quality
product or product at all in it.
You get paid for recruiting,
and it's kind of this circular,
well it's actually a pyramid,
but it's all based on
deception, and it's recognized
as illegal from the
Federal Trade Commission,
whereas an MLM, all multilevel marketing,
I'm not even gonna use the scheme,
a multilevel marketing company
usually has a viable
product that is being sold
and can be sold to someone
who's not a member of the thing,
but people get commissions on sales
and also people are encouraged to recruit.
Recruit other people to sell,
and like the multilevels to the marketing,
which could be likened
if you were to draw it
as a pyramid is an aspect of it,
because it's, you're not
just selling something,
but you're trying to get
people to sell things
underneath you so that when they sell,
you get, not only do
they get a commission,
but you get a commission
off of their sales.
And then that continues to go up.
That may not happen in every one of these.
That goes up the--
The pyramid?
Up the levels, yeah, and the pyramid gets,
the levels, there are
less people as you go up,
until it goes up to one
person who's in charge.
But the product that's being
sold is not a scam, right?
In a reputable MLM, which
I think all the ones
that we just mentioned
are presumably reputable.
They're legal, yes.
But the thing that we
want to talk about is
specifically what being a part of one
does to your friendships
and relationships,
because it does, especially
if not managed properly,
change the dynamic.
Yeah, and as an outsider sneaking in,
a friend of someone who's
inside of this thing,
her experience is pretty common.
You know, she has a negative view
of what her friend being
involved in the MLM
because of the way it's
impacting their relationship.
She's a bad friend because
it always comes back
to her either, to the MLM message,
which is hey, you should
buy these products from me,
or hey, you should also
sell these products.
There's an,
a lot of people get involved,
they don't have, they're
looking for a very flexible job,
they're looking for something that--
You can do from home.
You can do from home, you
can set your own hours,
and there's a promise
of being very lucrative.
Side story, when I worked at IBM,
there was a stint where my boss
on the side was involved in an MLM,
and the only reason I knew
this was because one day,
he asked me to go to lunch with him.
Uh-oh.
He had never asked me to go
to lunch with him before.
I mean, I go to meetings and he's there,
and like we have sometimes we
have a meeting in his office
where like, you know, I
would be held accountable
to the stuff I was
supposed to be working on,
but I'd never just go
to lunch with the guy.
He was a nice enough guy.
We go to lunch at like the,
some restaurant around the IBM campus.
Yeah.
And we get our food and we sit down.
And you're like what is about to happen?
All of a sudden, no, I'm like okay,
we're just getting lunch, hey,
this is a good opportunity.
Oh, you thought it was just lunch.
Thought it was just lunch.
It's never just lunch, Link.
Well get this, dude, all of a sudden,
he pulls out of his briefcase.
Oh, he has a briefcase.
He had like a, like a, um,
a wedge, like a cardboard wedge.
He puts it on the table,
it's just made of cardboard.
Did he want you to sit on it?
It was a pyramid.
No.
Well, it was a, it was a wedge, and then--
It was a presentation tool?
Yes, he pulled out a spiral-bound,
landscape-oriented notepad,
and then he, a flip freakin' book,
and he starts to open up the flip book
and he puts it on the
thing and he was like,
you know, I just wanted to tell you about
an opportunity for you to be your own boss
and make some extra money on the side.
Red flag.
As I've been doing, and I'm like--
This is before laptops apparently.
And I'm like hold on,
this is my freakin' what?
We worked for a company that made laptops.
Dude had a spiral-bound wedge.
You gotta admit there's
more drama in it though,
because he has to break out the stand
before you break out the notebook.
I started sweating, I'm like the heck?
Is he assembling a cardboard weapon?
Do I need to leave before
it becomes fully functional?
At least we were in public.
It wasn't like this was a clandestine,
it's like come to my garage, you know?
Which I think being in public
makes it all the more embarrassing,
because anyone who sees
you knows that you're now
on the receiving end
of an MLM presentation.
And we both, I'm sure you've seen it,
I've seen people having to
endure what I was enduring.
Get this, dude, I'll never forget it.
Okay dude.
The first slide, man,
when he flipped it over,
the first slide was--
A stock image.
Yes, a stock image--
Of humans.
Of a sports car.
Oh, ooh no, a red one, convertible?
It was a red sports car, yeah.
This could be yours.
Would you like to drive this, slick?
And he had this, I mean, it's not like,
the dude had people skills in normal life,
but something made him like,
he became this weird
android and he was like,
do you like fancy cars, and I'm like--
No, close that book.
Honestly, I was like uh.
Have you seen my car?
I'm not really, I'm not really,
no, I'm not really into sports cars.
I've never really gotten that.
Is there a pickup picture
that you can paste over this one?
You know what, that's what
you can do with the notebook.
I drove a non-extended
cab Tacoma at the time.
I remember that.
I could barely, I had
to get in it sideways.
I had to put my legs over your lap
in order to ride with you.
You did.
I told him I wasn't into
cars and then he's like,
he's unfazed, he's like
and he flips over--
How about women?
It was a mansion.
Oh.
It a freakin' picture of a mansion.
How about big houses?
You were like well actually
no, it's a lot to clean.
There's a lot of showers
that have to be closed.
A lot of potential for
pink slime to crop up.
I prefer a, have you
heard of a tiny house?
Of course, that was before tiny houses.
Why are you crying?
You think you're so funny?
Rhett thinks he's so funny
right now, and you are funny.
Yeah yeah yeah.
But you're not so funny
to make yourself cry.
Yeah well, I mean, that was--
Did you rub your eye or are you crying?
I feel like I was funny,
I feel like I've been funny
for like three times in a row.
Yeah, yeah, you're really,
you really need to start weeping.
So I'm like
uh, you know, Christy and I
just got married, you know this,
and we're house-sitting for a couple.
I mean, yeah, I would
like a big house some day,
but I'm not really into that.
Wow, what does he got on the next page?
So he's like
and he's like well what about,
and I don't remember what the picture was,
but there was a picture.
What a weird way to,
they didn't he say "do
you want more money?"
I mean, because most
people would be like yes.
Why you gotta attach monetary value
to anticipating what I'm gonna like?
I know, it's so weird.
He flips it over and
now he's hitting me with
would you like to give more to charity?
Oh, yeah.
I was like oh okay, so are you
about to present a charity?
No, he's about to present a
multilevel marketing campaign,
so if I join, he makes more money.
You can give more to charity.
No, so that he can get that
house and that car, man.
Yeah.
But he's guilting me with charity,
what am I supposed to say?
No, I'm not really interested
in giving more to charity.
I think it's a choose
your own adventure thing.
He probably wasn't just
going to the next page,
because I think they teach
you in the presentation,
they're like--
You think it's like a 911 flip book?
When you meet someone who
is not into material things,
go to charity.
Yeah.
And then if they don't like charity,
you would probably end the meeting.
Let me tell you something, brother,
he didn't skip a slide.
Okay.
So this is to catch everybody,
and that's how it's designed,
he's going on the script,
and it was so uncomfortable.
And it's wasn't fair, you know,
it makes me angry even now
because this dude's my boss.
I mean, it's like, I'm
not supposed, you know,
it's not appropriate.
You felt pressured.
Yeah, it's like, you can't--
You could've easily felt pressured.
Yeah, you have power over me as my boss,
and now I've got to, what, I gotta start,
and please train me how
to go up to strangers
in the magazine section of Barnes & Noble.
That's happened to me twice, by the way.
It has, right?
At Barnes & Noble in North Carolina,
that happened where people,
they started conversations
with me in like the coffee shop section,
and I was like this guy's being friendly
and it was that, it was MLM stuff.
It's not worth it to be that person
because you have to,
you get to a point where
you gotta sell your wars,
and again, I cannot remember
what company he was with
or what he was selling,
but you get to a point where you're either
going up to strangers, you're
being weird to strangers
in Borders book shop back in the day,
or you're hitting up your
friends and relatives,
and every time you're talking to them,
and there's a whole Facebook
component to it now.
Well that's what happens,
that is what has,
and I'm not really on Facebook,
and my wife isn't really anymore,
but she was for many years,
and that's what would happen.
You would have someone who
you haven't spoken with
since high school.
Yeah.
Who reaches out and asks a question
and you're like .
Hey how, I haven't spoken
to you in a long time,
how are you doing?
And then you respond to them
and they're like "I
couldn't help but notice,"
I'm gonna find some
segue into talking about
how you need this particular
product and it's like,
I don't feel like we have to explain
why that seems kinda
just dirty and deceptive.
I understand that, listen, I get it,
we sell things all the time,
we just tried to sell you
some stuff at Mythical.com,
but I think that we're
being pretty straightforward
with like okay, yeah, we sell merch,
go to the store and buy it if you want to,
but I don't try to sell my merch
directly to my friends that
I have relationships with,
and also I'm not trying to
then get them to sell it,
because I just don't want my friendships
to be defined by that.
It just, I know how it makes me feel,
I know how you felt in that situation,
and I know how it makes
me feel when I feel like
someone is trying to
enter into a transactional
relationship with me, and listen,
coming from two people
who live in Los Angeles,
which is the most transactional town
on the place of the fanet.
The face of the planet, any
time that you begin to sense
that someone is investing
their time into you
because of what you can
do for them financially,
it just feels bad, man.
Icky, icky.
And which you join an MLM, you are,
now in sure there's people, obviously,
humans tend to rationalize things,
so I'm sure there's people
who listen who right now,
and first of all, if
you're benefiting from it
financially or you've moved
way up into the organization,
there's absolutely nothing I can say
that's going to change your mind,
because you're going to
deflect anything that we say
that makes you feel uncomfortable because
you've got confirmation bias,
you want to continue to
confirm the fact that
you're in this thing and make
it okay, and that's fine,
I'm not trying to take you out of it.
I think what we're talking to is,
we're actually talking
to, what was her name?
@Sneakynin, and how you deal
with someone who's in it.
So we're not talking to
the person who's in it,
that's your deal, but
if you've got a friend
who's in it, I just
think the short answer is
you have to be honest.
Because the alterative is just saying
"I'm not gonna be your friend anymore."
Have a boundary conversation.
Listen, I'm not comfortable with
lacing our friendship with
ulterior motives, you know?
I don't know questioning
whether you want me
to buy something or help you sell things.
And then I think there's
probably a lot of people
who after they hear that from a friend
will be like oh, I'm sorry,
if that's the way you feel,
our friendship will
have absolutely nothing
to do with my involvement with this thing,
and I'll never talk about it,
you feel no pressure from me.
At that point, sure, you could
have a healthy friendship,
and I'm sure that's how
people who have found a way
to maintain healthy friendships
manage their relationships,
but the moment you cross that line,
you just have to think,
with any potential friend
that you have, the moment that
you make it about the MLM,
there's really no going back.
Unless the person is just
gonna be super honest with you
and you're gonna overcome
this confidently.
It puts the other person
in the difficult situation
that @Sneakynin is in, that
now they have to be the one
to like have this awkward
conversation with you
when this is really all your doing.
Yeah.
You know, it's like you've put them
in an awkward position
and you can rationalize it
and say "well they'll tell me,"
but it's extremely difficult
to tell somebody these things.
It's almost as difficult
as staring at your neighbor
while naked and bathing.
Right, but sometimes you
have to do these things.
And good things do happen,
but you gotta get over that hump.
Right.
And you know, maybe I'm
conflating things here,
but I remember early on in our marriage,
Christy would be invited
to a lot of parties.
That's the way a lot of them start.
Because what they'll do is,
it'll be for like selling kitchenware,
or I remember as a kid,
me and Mom and Jimmy and Emmy,
the four of us went to this like party
where they got all these
fancy pots and pans,
and they're talking about the
pots and pans for so long,
we were invited to a dinner party.
Where's the dinner?
There was no dinner, it
was just pots and pans.
Now they were cooking a bunch of stuff,
but we weren't allowed to eat it.
Three hours after we thought
we would have been eating,
we're freaking starving.
You're looking at empty things
that could have food in them.
They started making dinner
and then it's just like,
by the time we got the meal,
it was the best thing I'd ever eaten,
because I was about to die of starvation.
It was like 10 o'clock at night.
Well they wear you down so you're like
sure, whatever, I'll join,
give me the dag gum spaghetti.
And yeah, I was like,
you start to become like,
your brain became mush,
and by the end of it,
It's like a police interrogation.
Yeah, we're buying the pots and pans.
Keep them hungry.
And Jimmy are buying them because
the food tasted so good, it was just like,
but basically we were just,
had survived a near death experience.
It's like oh my god, thank
you for these pots and pans,
we gotta bring this home.
And there's these
freakin' jewelry parties,
and when Christy and I,
especially earlier on
in our marriage, we
were on a tight budget,
and I remember, you know
me, I'm very frugal.
Hm, really?
And it would just get my goat
when Christy would come
back from these parties
with her friends and
everyone would have been
highly pressured to--
I had to buy something.
Had to buy something.
Or else.
And if I bought enough,
then So-and-So who hosted
the party, you know she's
not doing well financially,
so it's like--
I think those young couples
are really, really susceptible
to this because again--
If I bought more, it would help her,
and then I'm like "but we
don't have the money for this."
You were guilted into buying things,
but because of group think.
Yeah, it's that kind of
like couples in their 20s,
it's like, that's where
a lot of it gets started
because you're all trying
to figure out a way
to make more money, I
understand the motivation,
and you're like we gotta
find something else,
we gotta supplement what we got going on,
and I'm not saying that
just across the board,
there's not a healthy way for
this type of company to exist
where you're kinda using
word of mouth and different,
because listen, there's all
kinds of ways to sell people
on something, I think it's
the fact that the main avenue
through which these things
work is through friendships.
And you can't just say
"hey, don't do this,"
because what I would say is
"don't do this with
friendships that you value,"
because if they said that at the big
feel-good seminar that you go to,
then who, only try this with people
who you don't really care
about the friendship.
Well that's not gonna work,
because those people
don't trust you as much.
And let's get in, yeah,
they build an entire
social construct and an identity structure
around being involved in the MLM.
And again, this goes back to my escape
as a kid and our family.
Now um, my stepdad at the time, Jimmy,
he was,
he was a drafter, what's
it called when you,
he wasn't an architect but he did draft,
you know, he was a drafter.
A draftsman.
Draftsman in the big city of Raleigh.
He'd go up there and he'd like,
he would draft all these plans,
and it was a cool freakin' job.
I remember going in there
and seeing everything
he was drawing, it was amazing.
I don't remember what
happened to that job,
but maybe he was unhappy, maybe,
I can't remember why
he stopped doing that,
but then there was a
period where it was like
okay, now he's a plumber, you know?
Which is amazing, I
mean, the dude went and,
he knew another trade or he figured it out
and he was, as far as I can
remember, doing pretty well,
but apparently not well
enough to not do other things.
Like I remember he was also for a while
he was selling vacuum
cleaners door-to-door.
Rainbows.
Not Rainbow, he was selling
Kirby, Kirby vacuum cleaners.
Like heavy-ass vacuum cleaners,
I'm talking like a 50-pound, solid metal.
Water-based, they're all water-based.
No, Rainbow is water-based,
but the Kirby was just, it was like--
Just heavy?
It was like steel.
Kirby, just heavy.
Just heavy, no water involved.
Now, in door-to-door salesman,
that, I mean, that's um,
that might make people feel uncomfortable,
but that's not sacrificing friendships.
I don't understand door-to-door salesmen.
I respect the fact that
to support his family,
he was doing, he was
exploring many options
to pull it together, and you know,
selling vacuum cleaners door-to-door
cannot be an easy job.
You know, and there's a lot
of pressure involved in that,
like going, just knocking
on people's doors
and then finding yourself
in their house vacuuming?
You know, and trying to sell them
this really expensive vacuum cleaner.
I mean, it's a lot more expensive
than the ones that you can buy at K-Mart
or Sky City at the time.
But it's not as heavy.
I mean, those are not as heavy.
And you know, there are,
there's not as much of that
going on, the Cutco Knives
thing is still happening.
In the first year of marriage,
Christy and I bought a
whole wad of Cutco knives,
which by the way, we still use.
You can't go up to
people's doors in general,
and now you can make
appointments for selling things,
but you can't just go
up to people's doors,
not anymore, man.
My point is, you know,
I don't want to over-criticize
my ex-stepdad Jimmy
for getting involved
in the MLM that he did,
because he was trying lots
of things to pull it together
for the fam, you know, so
I give him credit for that,
but we found ourselves involved in,
he became an insurance salesman.
So again, mostly by
appointments and referrals,
he was meeting with people
to sell term life insurance
through what was called
A.L. Williams at the time,
now it's called Primerica,
and if you look on Wikipedia,
I just wanted to verify that it was
a multilevel marketing organization.
Yeah.
It actually also says
in the Wikipedia that
a few years back, Forbes
ranked it in the top 50
most trusted I think it
was insurance companies.
Well, and again, that goes back to
what we talked about before,
regardless of the marketing methods,
it is a good product, that's
what that is saying, right?
Again, it doesn't mean
that the product is bad.
Right.
And I used to think that.
I used to think that
there must be something
wrong with this product
if it has to be sold
in this high-pressure way,
versus just being on the
shelf with other products,
but no, it's just a
different way to do it,
so it doesn't mean--
Which is very--
It could be great insurance
is all I'm saying.
Especially when it comes to something like
sports drinks and supplements or cleaners,
like with Amway, it's like
well I can just go to Target, you know?
It's like why do I have to be,
why do I have to experience
this higher pressure
in my home or sales pitch for something
that I can just get off of a shelf?
And the reason why is because, you know,
the prices are higher for something that
you could get off Amazon,
but again, they're trying
to work the margins
because, and they're also
trying to get you to sell it.
So the system generates money
for I guess the people at the top,
but the fact of the matter is,
a lot of people who get
involved in these things,
they just fizzle out,
but there's a whole world built around it
where you show up at conventions
and you start to feel good about it.
As a kid, I knew who this
guy A.L. Williams was,
it was like man, he started this company,
here's his success story.
Jimmy really bought into it.
We went down to Boca Raton, Florida.
Wow.
And there was this like
really fancy hotels
and they were all pink like
the slime in my shower.
And I was like wow, this is amazing.
It was one of the first
times we'd been on vacation
as a family.
Right.
But he had to go to all these pep talks,
seminars, and oh if we're really lucky,
you could get to see
A.L. Williams himself.
Mm-hmm.
At one of these things,
he was like a celebrity to these people.
They were like okay, you
gotta say through Sunday
but we'll have a church service
for any of you who want to go to that,
and it like became this
little community of like--
Well again, a lot of times,
some sort of faith component
gets inserted into this because
it begins to permeate so
many aspects of your life
and your relationships, so
why not add that component?
Because all that does is generate
even more community feel.
It makes you feel good about what, yeah.
You're part of a family.
You're a part of this thing,
and it, but it starts,
even at that young age, I was like,
I remember things that
now I interpret as just,
I felt weird as a kid because it's like,
I mean, cultish is a strong word,
but it has a little bit of
that vibe where it's like--
Well I don't know, any time,
I always get really
uncomfortable when people start
trying to combine faith with consumerism.
Like that seems like
a real special kind of
not good, you know?
And I'm not saying they were doing like
church services and touting
their insurance within it,
but they're tying their message together.
They're tying the two together.
Like we are so good, we're
good for you and we're good
for people that we're
doing these type of things,
and you know,
there's usually someone
or groups of people
with success stories that are tremendous,
they're like gifted motivational speakers.
So they sell all this hope
just like the flip book with the mansions
and the cars and stuff, and it's like.
Yeah.
You know, if you're down on your luck
or if you don't have direction,
and you need some, you need
to scratch it together.
You get everything, you get a community,
you get to make a living,
you get, there's no doubt that this is
an attracting thing to a lot of people,
that's why so many of
them are super successful.
And so then it becomes this odd,
evangelistic component of
going back to the people
that you're trying to
sell and you're no longer
selling them a product, you're
selling them a lifestyle
of either being rich or being happy.
You know, it's like you
start to take that out,
that energy out to people,
but when those people have
nothing to do with the thing,
the first thing they experience is just
this is freakin' weird.
Well because most--
Because it is.
Most people are able to
pick up on an agenda,
and for good reason,
we don't like it when we feel like
someone's actions are
motivated by an agenda
that we don't quite yet know what it is.
When you send me a message on Facebook,
I sense that there's an agenda,
but you're not sharing that with me.
When you invite me out to lunch,
seems a little bit weird,
there's some sort of agenda,
but I won't find out until you break out
the weird presentational booklet,
and that's just not a healthy
way to navigate friendships.
Friendships and relationships
are difficult as it is.
When you bring this other
layer of agenda into it,
it's going to make things more complex,
and you cannot blame someone
for having a problem with it
and being like "I don't want
to be your friend anymore"
or I definitely don't want our friendship
to be characterized by this.
So for us,
I mean, I only remember
going to that one seminar
that was a vacation where it was like,
we didn't get to do a
whole lot of vacation,
because it was like I had to stand outside
of these meetings that they were having.
Yeah, it wasn't very fun.
It was quite a downer.
You didn't see much of Boca or Raton.
I remember that Jimmy had an office
that had a whole slew of paperwork,
and then you know, stuff he was
trying to get off the ground
associated with this thing.
There would be some people
that he would get to like
work underneath him, but I don't recall
any of that really taking hold.
I remember there were certain people
that he seemed to idolize within the,
higher-ups within the organization
that were like okay, the
guy who brought me in,
the guy who brought him in,
I'm actually gonna get to meet today.
And it was just like,
this weirdness, you know,
that was like, how did it end for us?
I don't, well I think to put it simply,
they got, Mom and him got
a divorce and we moved out.
That's how it ended for you.
But I don't think it had anything to do
with the involvement, A.L. Williams
or Primerica, whatever it's called now,
did not have anything
to do with their divorce
or little breakup, I think
it was totally separate,
and I just think it simply fizzled out.
After a while of it not
working, a couple of years,
it's just like this isn't working for me.
You gotta buy in.
What am I doing?
You gotta buy in fully,
and those who do buy in
can experience a lot of success.
You can get that car and that house,
there's just a lot that
comes along with it.
So my language is a little overblown
that we escaped as if it were a cult,
but I do feel like it was, I mean we were,
when you go into that pink hotel
and you're going to all the seminars,
you're bought in, we were definitely
bought in for a little while.
But you made it out.
But we made it out.
And now you know how we feel about it,
but I think that the answer for @Sneakynin
is you just, you have to be honest,
you gotta say "I don't
want our relationship
"to be characterized by this,"
if you can bring yourself to that,
otherwise you're just gonna sort of,
the relationship will
probably just dwindle.
My summary critique of it is
if it's more about recruiting
people to do something
that you are also doing
instead of the product itself,
if you can't just isolate the
product on the open market
and give it an honest
comparison and it wins,
then you shouldn't believe in the product
enough to pour your whole life in
and change your whole lifestyle around it.
I mean, it's a bunch of smoke and mirrors,
it's selling a bunch of false hope.
Boil it down to the product
and make an honest assessment of it.
Do you have to have these
vitamins and this energy drink
and are you drinking their Kool-Aid?
Or should you actually just
compare it to Kool-Aid?
Is there a Kool-Aid one?
Because I might join that one.
Cool-Aid with a C,
like they went uncreative.
Well we took a long time
on that one, so let's--
It matters.
Let's answer another one here,
from Rachel Daniels, which this was is,
boy this hits so close to home for me.
What is the best way to sign off an email?
I always say "thanks" but
what about best or regards?
How do I know what's appropriate?
I have thought about this so thoroughly.
Now, I'll just start by
giving what my practice is,
and I feel stupid about
this, okay, I just feel dumb.
What I do is "thanks!"
with an exclamation point,
and I do it, that's
what I do almost always,
even though if I'm not
thanking you for anything.
Sometimes I won't do an exclamation point
if I feel especially like, I'm really,
there's nothing I'm thankful for at all,
so I guess I'm thanking you
for reading to this point?
I too, if I'm going to,
sometimes I'll just sign it "Link."
And then, the third
alternative is just "Rhett,"
there's nothing and then I
feel like I'm being cold,
I'm not being warm,
I'll do that in a reply
or a chain at that point
or I might actually
just drop my signature, they
know where it comes from.
In one sense, it's like when my dad puts
"love Dad" on a text, it's like Dad,
I know where, I see that
it's coming from you.
Emails work the same way,
do we really have to have a signature?
The from is at the top,
why put it at the bottom?
Now my default is to say "thanks," comma,
and then put "Link" underneath.
I've probably done that.
And I'm just, in terms of
what I'm thanking them for,
I'm thanking them for taking the time
to get that far in the
email, to actually read it.
It's not about the content of the email,
it's that okay, apparently
you've read it to this point.
But sometimes you are
thanking them for something,
so what if you are thanking
them for something?
Do you say "thanks for
that," and then you're like
"thanks for reading the email."
Do you double up?
No.
Or is it just an all-purpose thanks.
Because that's confusing.
Have you tried best or
kind regards or sincerely?
Sincerely sounds like
a letter, not an email.
I have friends who use best,
and lots of people that
I respect use best,
and I think the only
reason I can't use best
is that it's such a foreign thing
to the way that I think and speak,
and like no one said "best" growing up.
It would be, it's like
when all of a sudden,
somebody says "I want you to call me Ricky
"instead of Richard," like, why?
You know, I can't start using best,
what is he trying to prove?
It almost feels like at
the end of your email,
you would sign like, James McLaughlin.
It's not that it's false,
but it's not what you go by.
That's also my middle
name and my last name.
I know.
I'm just saying it wouldn't be false,
but it would be a little
weird, a little improper.
Or R.J.
R.J.?
Yeah, I do feel like saying
"best" is that weird,
because my criteria for
the tone of my emails is
if I was standing beside
you as you read this
and I was reading it out lout to you--
Would I have said "best?"
Is it something I would have said?
Definitely wouldn't say "regards."
Yeah, it's, it's,
but I think the flip side of this,
because I'm on your side,
but the flip side is
we are pointing out the lost
art of the written letter.
Lando's teacher invites people to,
friends and family
members to write letters
addressed to the kid in the
class through the school,
because she wants to teach kids
the lost art of letter-writing,
and whenever kids get a letter,
she's like they're so excited.
Okay, it's letter time, some
people have got letters.
A parent can write a letter,
like outside the school,
or like a grandparent or?
Yeah, yeah.
And just, okay, got it.
I've been writing your kids for years.
Okay, good, best.
It is the best.
But then she said "what they
don't know is if they do
"get a letter, then I make
them write a letter back
"and they have to learn what that's like."
I think that we're applying
this colloquial conversational
criteria to email signatures
because we don't appreciate the fact,
there's nothing wrong with
the formality of a letter,
and I think best, I mean,
you hated sincerely,
but is it just gone or
is it something that
we should try to embrace and open up to
as an answer to this question?
Sincerely, Link.
Well you know, I feel like sometimes,
and I think this applies to texts as well.
If you were to write "thanks" period
at the end of your email.
Uh-huh.
It would send a little bit
of a shudder through someone,
like oh, whoa, what did I do wrong?
I gotta reread this email.
Because of the period?
The period.
Yeah?
And I don't, I track
with what you're saying,
but I feel like trying
to somehow recapture
the essence of letter-writing
and put that back into emails,
we're beyond that.
It's gone.
First of all, I don't think
that our kids use email,
I think email is becoming
almost exclusively
a business thing,
and because the way that it
keeps the threads together
and you can group things
and it's the kind of way,
when you need to
communicate about something
business-ish or businesslike,
you need to communicate in that way,
and then some people are,
I don't really know what the criteria is
for me deciding to send a Slack message
to someone here at work
or to send an email,
but I will say that I often,
because you can just as easily create--
A group?
A group in the same
way that you can create
a group on email.
What I'm getting at is I don't know what
the application for this will be,
because I think that all
the emails that I send
at this point are either I'm trying,
look all right I'm gonna
have this thing at my house
and I don't want to go
through the formality
of creating an e-vite for
it or something like that,
it's just like hey, I'm
sending you information,
and then what do I say at the end of it?
If it's to a bunch of friends,
I'll sign off in some way
that's just supposed to
be fun and cute and funny,
but I don't have a default.
For me this is what do I say
when I send a business email?
And I know that if I just
transition completely
to best, it would be like hm, okay,
he's got his, he's buttoned up.
There's something cool about best though,
because it's says no matter--
Maybe it's the best response.
I hated it when we first
started talking about it,
but just hear me out.
Any written word is open to
so much misinterpretation,
you know, and it burdens me that
so many things happen over text or email
that with a simple
face-to-face conversation
or even a phone call, crises
would have been averted
left and right, misinterpretation,
feelings being hurt,
you know, restless nights of analyzation
of what did he mean?
Is so-and-so upset, there
was a period at the end
of the thanks, you know?
You know, the simple four-letter word.
You think best is gonna solve this?
Best really captures,
no matter what you think
or might have read between the lines
or have interpreted
from what I've written,
just know that my intentions were good.
I only meant the best.
Okay let's examine a test case
because I don't agree with you on this,
because if I write you an email
and the last sentence in the email is
"and that's why I think you're an ass."
Mm-hmm.
Best.
That's like gosh.
You know what I'm saying?
That doesn't work, that's
condescending at that point.
First of all, when I did
get that email from you,
I didn't even notice the closing.
Yeah because I said "thanks!"
With an exclamation point
because I do it out of habit.
I'm just trying to give it its best shot,
because I do think it's a problem.
I don't think there's an answer,
and I hate to be, I hate to say that.
If there was an ending that could do
what best is trying to
do, I would be all for it,
but I think we're so self-aware
and we're so judgemental as
people that like, we always,
it's like well that's
weird, that's pretentious,
it's not something you
would say, so why type it?
Like regards, yeah.
Yeah, it's like get off your high horse,
or get in the real world.
We're just communicating here, be normal.
How about just something like--
Like what are you, in an MLM or something?
And here's the thing, at this point,
I don't think you, this
isn't the situation
where you can invent a new phrase
because then you're just weird.
Like if I was just like
you know what I'm gonna do?
When I get done with an email,
I'm just gonna be like "yup, Rhett."
You know what I'm saying?
Quirkles, Link.
It's almost like--
Quirkle time.
'Cause yep would work,
because it would be like,
you know how like, okay--
That's how my dad--
Because I also, I'm the guy that usually,
if I'm not too busy, I
read through the email
that I just typed to
make sure that it doesn't
say something crazy, and
so I read back through it
and then I'm like "yep, send," you know?
It's what you actually said.
Yep, that's what I meant to
say, Rhett, signature, gone.
Why don't you just type
"okay, sending now, pressing send."
How about "this message has been
"approved by Rhett McLaughlin."
My gosh, that's stupid.
Eh, that feels just, yeah,
it would have to be an automatic
signature or something.
That's like a dad joke,
whose kids decided not to talk to him
five years ago, you know?
What about "sent from my phone?"
Because that still is
the automatic signature
on my emails on my phone.
Get rid of that crap.
That is done, people, sent from my phone
is just an excuse for
not re-reading the email
or not taking the time
to write, I mean, just,
no one cares about email.
Don't apologize for
something you don't know
if you said or not.
I've gotten so close to taking
sent from my phone, first of all,
it used to say like "sent from my iPhone."
You're right, because that was a default.
And that felt pretty
pretentious, I have an iPhone.
Now mine just says "sent from my phone,"
and the reason that I have
not taken it out of there
is because auto-correct, man.
Sometimes your phone
will do something that
you're keyboard would never do,
and so it's just like did he just,
does he want me to kill the whale?
I don't have--
Or does he want me to save the whale?
I don't have anything,
I just tested myself,
there's nothing, I don't have a signature.
Oh my phone I don't even have a signature.
On my work stuff I have a signature.
Yeah but, and I understand like
we've got a lot of people
here who have signatures.
I'm sorry, I'm just deleting emails now,
I gotta clean that mailbox.
You know you've got the
Mythical Entertainment,
you know, logo and you've got your title
and you've got your contact information,
I think that's important depending on,
you know, what your job is.
Here's what I think it should be.
But that's not a signature.
Well here's what--
No that's a signature, that's not,
what do you call it, what is the?
Sign-off.
I think the sign-off,
here's my proposed solution.
Salutation?
That's the opening, hello.
What is the correct letter
term for that though?
See, we've lost all this.
You should know this,
this the kind of thing
that you would remember from school.
I'll need to ask Lando's teacher.
The closing of a letter is called the?
The de-salutation.
Desalinization.
I don't know what it's called,
but this is what I think it should be.
I think when you read
back through your email,
you get in the rhythm of
hey, I'm reading this,
I'm thinking, I'm putting
my mind in the head space
of the person who's receiving this,
I'm reading back through it to make sure
nothing dumb is in there,
and then when I get to the bottom,
having gotten the momentum of
just reading back through it--
When you get to the, what do you call it?
Valediction or complimentary close.
Complimentary closer, closing.
Complimentary closing, I'll remember that.
The valediction.
I was the valedictorian
at my high school class.
You read back through it and you're like
getting the vibe, putting
yourself in their shoes,
and then you just, whatever
you feel like you would have
said if you would have
given that as a speech,
you say it at that point.
Thanks, yup, hitting send now.
You're 100% right.
And just whatever you feel is added on.
It's never the same,
sometimes it might be best.
Sometimes it might be
a middle finger emoji,
do they make that?
Yeah.
Yeah, that.
Jenna is adamantly nodding yes.
Is that your complimentary closing?
The middle finger?
The middle finger emoji?
What is yours?
I mean, you're our assistant,
you communicate on our
behalf, what is your closing?
It depends.
It depends on who I'm talking to and--
You know what time it is.
It's a lot of times thanks
with an exclamation point.
Thanks, exclamation point.
The last email she sent to us
was thanks with an exclamation point.
Oh yeah, I always send
exclamations to you all.
You are usually asking us
to do something though.
Yes.
Our job is more about you
asking us to do things
than us asking you to do things.
Thanks exclamation point is more like,
in anticipation of your
compliance, I am thanking you.
Right, here's all the things that you guys
should be doing that I've asked you about.
Thanks for trying.
I think you just need to--
I think that works, I
think you're doing great.
But if you don't put
anything, you are a jerk.
It either, you might be seen as a jerk.
Well--
He just signed Rhett.
He didn't even take the time
to put a complimentary closing.
Every time somebody does that though,
I respect them though.
I said what I wanted to say,
and I just want you to
remember who said it.
It's a power play,
it's like staring at
someone from your shower.
See, I don't need more
power, I've got so much.
Wonder if it was just
the staring eyes emoji?
Can it just translate into an email?
I'm always watching.
Is there a showering naked?
I'll be watching you.
I don't know that we've
helped in this one,
but we gotta stop.
I'll never delete this,
I'm keeping a record of this, Rhett.
#EarBiscuits, give us
your complimentary closing
and why it's the best if
you don't think it's best.
We tried so hard to get to
give you what you needed,
to give you an answer.
Sorry Rachel Daniels.
Link went out there, you
believe so hard in best,
but I dismantled it very quickly,
and now we're left with
it's what you make it, man.
All the best.
Always the best.
Always!
Always, always.
That's a bit too love letter-ish.
How about all way?
All the way.
Best all the way.
Uh, okay, I don't think we've helped.
I think love, you know?
The word could use a little bit more love.
I say love to my mom
if I sent her an email.
What about for a whole month,
every email you send,
no matter to who it is--
Has to be love?
It's just love.
Sounds like a David Dobrik
bet, it's like, you know?
Okay, you don't want to, okay,
then maybe it would be good then.
Right, yeah, maybe we'll get views.
Love.
I don't think David Dobrik
would do an email prank.
I think that really shows how old we are.
#EarBiscuits, let us know what you think
about all the stuff.
Do you have a rec?
If you want to defend MLM, go for it.
My recommendation I'll keep it quick is
Ken Burns's "Country Music,"
I've been watching that,
you know, every episode is, I
think there's eight of them,
it's a documentary on the meticulous
development of the amazing
and best, I wouldn't say best genre,
I can't say that, I was
just trying to work best in,
but I'm very fond of the genre.
One of the better genres.
Country music, lots of Merle Haggard,
one of his last interviews
before his death.
It was tough to watch the first episode
because I was, you
know, since he's passed,
but it's cool to see him, he's
got that gleam in his eye.
How many hours of a commitment is this?
Probably 16 to 18.
Oh, yeah.
So that's my recommendation,
go to PBS.org, look
for your local listing.
If you want to stream it and
they're not shown anymore,
you have to give them a little donation,
but hey, it's worth it.
Ken Burns was thinking about
watch time before YouTube.
Yeah, he was.
The king of watch time.
We'll speak at you next week.
Thanks for hanging out,
and if we offended you, you know what,
just introspect a little bit.
Yeah, I'll meet you at the Barnes & Noble
in the coffee shop, I'll be the one
with a cardboard prop-up
for my presentation.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.